ladakh india is home to one of the
highest optical telescopes in the world
its environment makes it ideal for
stargazing
when we step out at night and look up at
the sky it is mesmerizing
we can
see clearly the constellation
the
galaxies
and the stars
[Music]
my name is sevan doji
and i'm working here at
indian astronomical observatory as
mechanical engineer
the indian astronomical observatory is
spread across 120 acres of land and
located at the northern tip of india
it consists of two optical telescope 2
meter telescope
0.7 meter telescope and area of
gamma-ray telescope
the remoteness of its location makes it
ideal for astronomical study
pandey is a very good location for sky
observation
first of all entire ladakh is actually
high altitude cold desert it is in rain
shadow region of himalayas so there is
very little rainfall and
hardly any snowfall
so cloud cover is very little so
observations are possible almost
throughout the year
[Music]
[Music]
we are mainly observing two type of
sources
firstly we observe objects called
pulsars
secondly we are observing some sources
which are outside our galaxies
these are active galactic nuclei
the observatory's altitude of
approximately two and a half miles above
sea level allows the scientists to
collect a wider range of data than they
would at lower levels
but the isolated location means that
often the only other people the
scientists and engineers see
are the occasional tourists
we receive lots of visitors mainly in
summer who are wanting to see the
telescope
when i came here first time i was quite
impressed to see the quality of sky here
extremely clear skies
just amazing experience
[Music]
whether you're looking up as an
astronomer
or just a traveler
there's no night sky quite like this
you